I'm officially single officially
supported 90-day fiance star Fernanda
flores his divorce is final and frankly
she couldn't be happier on Monday the
reality star shared the big news on
Instagram posting these pics outside of
a chicago courthouse writing as she is
officially single and no longer married
to her ex Jonathan Rivera and of course
[Music]
she added quote by forgiving and closing
chapters you open your heart to more
blessings to come in your way this isn't
a failure this is a win excited to see
what God has planned for me
Fernanda also shared that clip dancing
out of the courthouse Fernanda
celebrated the news on her instant
stories - showing off her do and writing
freemen and a new hairstyle feels so
good I just hope I use the video of my
earlier in the morning in court she also
encouraged fans to check out her YouTube
page where she shared a video about
being divorced at 21 years old it was
like a dark awful moment a lot of pain a
lot of bullying
a lot of bad things and I'm solving that
there wasn't an ending but she said
after her day in court she felt like a
new woman honestly it felt good you felt
very good because for a month I cried
every day about that situation and
asking God to give me peace in my heart
and fine teeth too to give me strange
needs to make me strong Juno to give me
give me that according to the
intelligence I needed to know how to
deal with the entire situation because
oh I am I'm 21 okay now she says she's
focusing on the future a couple
announced that they were parting ways
back in January 2019 at the time
Jonathan hit up insta live to confirm
the news saying quote Fernanda and I
will remain friends I think he give
everything in a relationship in a
marriage that you can I will give
everything I can to the next person in
my life following their announcement for
nine that took a break from social media
but broke her silence about the
separation on YouTube in June as viewers
might recall Fenn and I found another
woman's underwear in her ex's house but
according to her a lot of what happened
after the incident went down off-camera
pictures movies stuff like do it you're
supposed to let your past behind and
start fresh with me I know that you're a
single man I know that you're older than
me I don't know I I wasn't I wasn't
understanding why and I realized that
not everything is how it seems
[Music]